today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video it is
Thursday which means we have the latest
jobs numbers and they're not good when
we added the jobs lost
in the last week or last week I guess I
would say that puts the total number of
jobs lost during the seven weeks of what
we would I guess called the coronavirus
quarantines at thirty three and a half
million jobs last week the latest
numbers about 3.2 million more people
lost their jobs and filed for
unemployment now if you are looking at
these numbers and you are determined to
find some okay news or some sign of it's
not as bad as it could be what you could
say and you would be right to say it is
that each day I'm sorry each week fewer
people are losing their jobs we had more
than six million people lose their jobs
in the first in the last week of March
the first week of April only about half
of that number each week over the last
couple of weeks have lost their jobs in
the three million job range but in total
these are unconscionable numbers now to
give you a little bit of context before
this all started so seven weeks ago
eight weeks ago the US workforce was
believed to be about a hundred and fifty
eight million people 158 million people
were formerly in the workforce in the
United States before this all started so
when you look at thirty three and a half
million jobs that is twenty one percent
of the labor force of the United States
that has lost their jobs not in a year
which would be a tragedy in seven weeks
in seven weeks if three months ago
somebody had said in the next three
months one out of five Americans who is
working is going to lose their job
number one no one would have believed it
but if you forced their hand to say how
do you think the stock market would be
doing how do you think all these if they
would say well it would be absolute
complete devastation but nobody would
believed that that is how bad things
could possibly get in such a short
period of time but we are there now
previously before this phase before
coronavirus the largest one-week job
loss new unemployment claims was
somewhere in the 600,000 range maybe
close to 700,000 we have done five to
ten times those numbers not in total
during coronavirus each week during the
last seven weeks and again the total
number is now thirty three and a half
million jobs lost now there are people
who are seeing these numbers and they're
in the camp of open it all right now no
matter what to save the economy right
there they're in that camp
and those folks see these numbers and
they say here's the evidence here's the
evidence that we must reopen everything
right now regardless of the human cost
and by the way the human cost is really
big anyway with things shut down which
is true and that tells us just how
contagious coronaviruses that's a very
short-sighted perspective it's not a
good idea but I do believe that there
are things that we can glean from these
numbers that should inform what should
have been done and also how things
should be handled going forward first of
all even economies that appear to be
doing well Trump has called the economy
up until seven weeks ago the best
economy in the history of any country
ever I don't call it that but there's no
doubt that what we had up until seven
weeks ago was an economy that by the
normal metrics we use unemployment
inflation consumer confidence stock
market all of those measures it was
doing well it was an economy that was
doing well but what we learned is even
those economies are extremely fragile
even those economies can on the drop of
a dime make a hundred and eighty degree
turn this fragility is inherent to our
economy in part because of the marginal
nature of a lot of the work in the
economy in part because of the low
savings rate which is fueled by stagnant
wages over a long period of time
dramatic inequality also gives you a
verage --is that seem okay even when a
lot of individuals are in a very
precarious financial State the
just-in-time nature of many of our
industries and supply chains all of
these things should confirm to us that
even when
the economy looks pretty good by the
standard metrics it's a very fragile
economy that we have that's part of the
system that's a feature of it not a bug
number two what we also need to think
about is if you look at other countries
right now if you look at Italy France
Spain a lot of these hubs of cases South
Korea of course they're all on the
dramatic decline they are doing really
really well while we are still having
2,500 deaths a day and that leads me to
have to talk about Donald Trump's
failure here now I'm not gonna do this
completely irrational thing where I
could sit here and tell you Trump
obviously should have shut everything
down On February 20th when we had 15
cases Trump was very dumb and wrong to
say on febrile 8 February we have 15
cases and it'll soon be 0 that was a
dumb thing to say no president is going
to shut down a country with 15 cases I'm
not gonna sit here and tell you that
that's the logical thing that should
have been done at the time but don't
look at February 20th look at March 5th
look at March 10th okay on March 5th we
had 221 cases here in the United States
on March 5th China had 80 thousand cases
proving that this could go very very big
but importantly Italy had 4,000 cases on
March 5th so on March 5th
we knew 15 cases weren't going to zero
we went to 21 we knew that a country
could have close to a hundred thousand
cases and we knew that another country
could have the disease seated and
already have 4,000 cases that's what we
knew from Italy so March 5th would not
have been a crazy time to say hey
governors all 50 of you we need to stay
at home starting now if we had done that
on March 5th I'm not saying February
20th but if we had done it on March 5th
we would now have done 60 days of it and
we would have had economic impacts
similar to what we've had but we would
be in very good shape right now compared
to where we are by mid March when the
sporadic stay at home orders started in
some states but not others the US
had already been seated with close to
4,000 cases of coronavirus it was too
late then to really stop the spread it
was especially not going to happen when
only some states started stay-at-home
orders in the middle of March so don't
fall for the trumpets talking point that
there were no cases in February and so
it would have been crazy to shut it down
then they are right I don't know of any
president that with 15 cases would have
demanded or asked 50 governors to shut
things down but by early March March 5
March 7 look at the numbers for
yourselves we had the data that we
needed to take it seriously and Trump
did not at that point in time he'll brag
he shut down travel from China but but
clearly at that point it had gone
outside of China to a significant degree
and we now have 33 million jobs lost but
because of this rolling patchwork of
shutdowns in some states and not in
others we see some states improving some
worsening we still have 2,500 deaths a
day and FEMA and the CDC believe it is
possible that by June 1st we will
actually be up to 3,000 deaths every
single day it's been mishandled let's be
accurate in our criticism of how it's
been mishandled but it has been
dramatically mishandled and not only are
we seeing a human toll we are also
seeing an optional economic toll we were
going to have an economic impact but we
could have you know grinned and bared it
for 60 days starting March 5th and we
would be in much better shape right now
a random black man who was according to
some out for a jog has been shot dead by
two white men who chased after him
claiming he looked like a burglar that
had been in the neighborhood the story
is a tragedy and there have been no
arrests at this point in time now I'm
not pretending to know everything about
the story I'm gonna tell you what we
believe is the case so far
Ahmad our burry 25 years old this
happened February 23rd it's been months
in Brunswick Georgia the video has
recently been released our burry was
running through the sea till assures
neighborhood he was chased by 64
year-old Gregory McMichael and his 34
year-old son Travis McPike
now I'm gonna play some of the video for
you a part of a video of part of the
incident for you it is relatively
graphic heads up in case you want to
skip ahead it's about 30 35 seconds of
video you're listening and not watching
you'll be able to see the video on our
YouTube clip or find it elsewhere online
very easily let's take a look
no one has yet been arrested for this
although it has been more than two
months since the incident took place so
here's the story as it has now been
pieced together and it is certainly not
a complete story
to date the McMichaels father and son
they saw our burry as they claim quote
hauling ass
that's the term they used and they
thought that must be the burglar who's
been burglarizing houses in this
neighborhood
so the McMichaels grabbed a 357 Magnum
and a shotgun
one for each got into their pickup truck
and started chasing a mod our burry a
third man also joined the chase in their
pickup truck they caught up to our burry
and Gregory McMichael reportedly shouted
at him to stop and this created a
confrontation of sorts McMichael claims
are burry started attacking his son
Travis a scuffle ensued potentially over
control of the shotgun that Travis
McMichael had which led to a shot being
fired and subsequently a second shot
being fired
our burry did not have a weapon and he
was shot dead at the scene
now the next step would be according to
officials for this to go to a grand jury
but it's important to understand that
it's not necessary to wait for a grand
jury to make arrests and we're going to
talk about that in a moment we have a
statement from director Vic Reynolds of
the Georgia Bureau of Investigations of
the Georgia Bureau of Investigation and
he talks about the case and listened to
the hemming and hawing that's going on
here
I offered our assistance in this matter
mr. Durden and I were able to connect
and speak about 9:30 last night and he
quickly accepted our offer and asked us
to become involved in the case some of
you may not realize but the GBI can only
become involved in a matter when asked
by the local authorities after mr.
Doran's request last night I advised him
that we would hit the ground running
this morning we've now assigned this
case to three of our experienced
supervisory level agents they come from
two separate regions and a specialized
unit which is located in the third
region we've also decided that this
we'll be ran from headquarters that will
bring to bear every resource and all the
experience this agency has in resolving
this matter either our goal in every
investigation is to seek the truth so
listen guys this is on video now I admit
the video doesn't show us the start of
the incident and I'm gonna talk about
that in a moment but it's been months a
lot of it is on video this is a huge dog
and pony show now why have there not
been any arrests I'm going to do the
best job I can at laying out the case
for not arresting anyone yet okay now I
want to be really clear disclaimers I'm
not saying this case that I'm in about
to I'm about to lay out resonates with
me I'm gonna make the strongest case I
can to play devil's advocate okay
the McMichaels were legally carrying
their guns the 357 Magnum and the
shotgun were legally open carried based
on Georgia law so having the guns with
them is not legally a problem they begin
to pursue someone that they believe to
be a burglary suspect now you and I
might say listen this resembles a
burglary suspect it was just a guy who
happened to be black that this is racism
there's race that explains what went on
here that's fine it is still not illegal
to pursue someone again under Georgia
law who they believe to be a burglary
suspect now you and I understand that
this term burglary suspect is absolutely
crazy we're just talking about a guy who
happens to be black but I'm trying to
lay out a legal case here so we can see
both sides of this Georgia law says a
private person may arrest an offender if
the offense is committed in the presence
are with an immediate knowledge the
video starts during a confrontation
where there is already a scuffle between
our burry and one of the McMichaels now
again under Georgia law if indeed our
burry was attacking or trying to take
the gun from McMichael McMichael would
be allowed to use up to deadly force in
that situation now the video starts too
late to see how this all started we
don't have the story of the dead guy we
only have the story of
McMichaels who of course don't want to
be arrested and charged here now I want
to be really clear I believe that these
two should have been arrested and then
let the legal system work what what I'm
pointing out is that there is a case
some are making for why it's logical
that nobody has been arrested yet but I
have a different perspective we have a
system of justice people are innocent
until proven guilty I'm not saying
anything about the legal guilt of the
McMichaels that would be for a court
sort out what I am saying is that this
is clearly meeting the standard for it
to be in the legal system
if the racial circumstances were
reversed if this were two black men with
guns or three men in a pickup truck who
identified a guy that resembled the
burglar only in that he was white and
the burglar was believed to be white the
two or three black men would have been
arrested and charged and it would be up
to them to mount a legal defense at this
point they might be guilty legally they
might be not guilty legally it would be
up to the state to prove it in a court
of law but they would have been arrested
and charged by now in this case it's
been more than two months
no one's been arrested merely on the say
that the victim resembled a possible
burglar in that he was black this is
laughable now again you don't have to
take a position on guilt or innocence to
critique the situation you have people
on the right saying the McMichaels have
the presumption of innocence until
proven guilty and that is exactly right
they do there is no argument for me on
that but nothing has happened to even
put them in a position of being tried
and that is what doesn't make sense when
you think about how this would have gone
down if the circumstances were only
slightly different but if you disagree
with me if I missing something by all
means let me know I want to get it right
that's what matters I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman quick break right back after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are larry crater and diane McSwain
larry and diane thank you so much for
your support also want to say thanks to
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day someone who not only signed up
but stuck it out for almost 5 years
that's Tracy Floyd thank you so much
Tracy grab a membership it's very quick
and it's extremely rewarding you get the
daily bonus show and commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show just
for you as a member sign up at join
pakman.com I invite you to join the
discussion on the David Pakman show
reddit at david pakman.com slash our EDD
i tea more than 19,000 of you have
already done that a few interesting
posts i spotted one is about the suicide
rate that donald trump has been talking
about lately asking why does no one ever
question Trump on the high suicide rate
falling life expectancy and rising
opioid usage before kovat 19 whenever he
brings them up as a reason to reopen the
country yeah this is a very fair
question we are being gas-lit daily by
Donald Trump when Donald Trump pulls out
a piece of paper from his suit jacket
with a graph of the just number of tests
that the United States has done we are
being gas lit right we are a country of
331 million people and what matters is
the per capita testing rate when Donald
Trump now says listen staying home can
make people depressed people could
commit suicide people are addicted to
drugs these are things Donald Trump has
not indicated he ever cared about before
and they were problems before so you're
completely right to point out the
cynical nature of that and I wish Donald
Trump were asked about it but you know
he would just lie and move on to the
next question another user says reminds
us that Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg is
in the hospital with an infection which
is not good news and I want to just take
this as an opportunity to remind
everybody that we want Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg
ever and we wish her the best and we
want her to stay on the court she says
she wants to be on it until she's 90 and
we want her to be able to do that and
that's absolutely fantastic and we love
her and it reminds us of the fact that
there is a level of dread that we
experience when we hear that she's in
the hospital
and we know that Donald Trump is
president and gets to pick Supreme Court
justices just a reminder about the
importance of who is allowed to select
the next Supreme Court justice very very
important lastly a post on our subreddit
from user Jon X wall who says how can
you prove you are not a sexual assault
er I don't know the answer to this I
think that this is something that needs
to be discussed and you all know my
positions on on allegations of sexual
assault I believe that as a general rule
these need to be taken seriously they
need to be investigated we need to
ensure that men or women who are victims
of sexual assault are not dissuaded from
coming forward because of how they
expect to be treated or shame or
whatever else I don't know how you prove
that you didn't sexually assault someone
when there is not a criminal proceeding
I think that many of us if there is
actually a criminal trial about rape for
example and the individual is found not
guilty of course we all know you can be
found not guilty and have actually done
the thing you were accused of but
legally be not guilty but I believe that
there is more of a sense that when
you're found not guilty of rape you
didn't do it even though of course that
that's not always the case when you have
an allegation that never gets to a
police report or a criminal proceeding
and the accused perpetrator denies it I
don't know how you prove you didn't do
it I really don't and sir I don't even
have anything to add I would leave it to
you to give me some thoughts about that
join these discussions at david
pakman.com slash read it
alright let's dig in my friends to the
topic of coronavirus and vitamin D
here's why I'm doing this
medical research is looking at so many
different things when it comes to
coronavirus everything from testing
antiviral therapies looking at
convalescent plasma transfusions of
antibodies looking at you know our cases
more severe in cities with more air
pollution versus cities with less air
pollution all of these things are being
looked at and they should be but when we
throw a whole bunch of stuff out it can
be hard to really think through just one
element of this any of these could be
fruitful in thinking of how to treat the
virus but we really want to dig in
deeply and and think through all of
these different possibilities so one
thing that's coming up more and more is
the connection between coronavirus
deaths and low levels of vitamin D so
let's explore it vitamin D is most
importantly for humans something that
helps us absorb calcium magnesium and
phosphate and humans can get vitamin D
from the Sun you go outside you get it
from from UV light and from very few
foods fish is the big one sometimes
mushrooms if the mushrooms have absorbed
UV UV light as they were growing there
are many countries that when you buy
milk the milk is reinforced supplemented
with vitamin D some breakfast cereals
are supplemented with vitamin D okay but
vitamin D has been controversial over
the years for a while it was very much
in fashion to do a significant
supplementation of vitamin D then we
learned more about high vitamin D
toxicity and so we've backed off of that
a little bit but for a while if you were
below 30 nano grams per milliliter let's
just call it 30 right with the exact
measure doesn't doesn't matter but if
you were below 30 in vitamin D you were
considered to be low and should be
supplementing more recently 22:30 has
sort of been considered okay and a lot
of people now say a lot of medical
professionals say you really only need
to supplement if you're below 20
nanograms per milliliter of vitamin d
there's not a hundred percent agreement
on that there is also the general idea
although the specifics are always
complicated that low vitamin D can
increase all cause mortality basically
low vitamin D can make you more
predisposed to die
and that you are generally more
susceptible to diseases of various types
if your vitamin D is low so how does
this relate to coronavirus well it
relates because we now have a bunch of
studies that have found correlations
between coronavirus deaths and serious
cases of corona virus and low levels of
vitamin D particularly with levels of
vitamin D under 20 to some degree people
with vitamin D between 20 and 30 and
very infrequently are the deaths
happening in people with a vitamin D
level above 30 now right away our
critical thinking skills should kick in
and say David is this correlation or is
this causation and that's exactly the
right question because if this is causal
it would imply that if you take vitamin
D and raise your level to 30 your odds
of dying from coronavirus or having a
serious case go down dramatically
but we don't know that we don't know
that it is possible that the people who
died with low vitamin D died because of
some third factor that causes low
vitamin D let me give you an example if
I'm suffering from severe cardiovascular
disease and I am inside a lot because my
mobility is decreased I could have a
predisposition to die from coronavirus
because of the cardiovascular disease
and I might have low vitamin D because
I'm not going outside very much because
of the cardiovascular disease in other
words if you have cardiovascular disease
and you take vitamin D you might not be
protecting yourself from a corona virus
death we don't know is the point what
does the caller scholarship say so far
we have a bunch of different studies we
can look at there's one paper called
vitamin D level of mild and severe
elderly cases of kovat 19 a preliminary
report looked at a hundred and
seventy-six patients over age 60 who had
severe kovat 19 and indeed a lot many of
them a lot of them had very low vitamin
D another study called vitamin D
deficiency as a risk factor for severe
kovat 19 looked at 186 patients and
again they found that the coronavirus
patients had lower vitamin D than the
median population at large in particular
men so does this tell us vitamin D
protects you from coronavirus no it does
not sadly no there's also another
complicating factor because there are
studies which find that vitamin D levels
go down when the body suffers a
traumatic event for example a surgery
but there is also speculation that if
you get a lung infection or lung
inflammation that can reduce your
vitamin D so if that's the case corona
virus could be lowering vitamin D levels
making the case for vitamin D being a
protective force even less clear if you
get a lung inflammation and it lowers
your vitamin D if you then supplement
vitamin D does that protect you we just
don't know so where do I come away with
this here's my perspective and it's not
my opinion it's from what I've read from
medical experts
it seems that maintaining a vitamin D
level above 30 without going up into the
toxic range is generally a good thing
vitamin D is really cheap you can get it
for free from the Sun taking care to
protect your skin of course it's one of
the cheapest supplements that you can
buy so I recently got an at-home vitamin
D test it was you know the end of the
Boston winter I have not been outside as
much as I'm outside during the summer
and my level was thirty point five just
above that minimum so I am NOT
supplementing I eat plenty of fish I'm
spending more time outside now as long
as my level doesn't go super high
there's very little risk and very little
cost to ensuring that I maintain above a
30 in vitamin D seems reasonable to me
of course always consult with your
doctor this is a general consensus from
the medical community and not advice for
any individual that's vitamin D and
coronavirus by next week we may know
more press secretary Kaylee Mackin Annie
held her second press briefing yesterday
you might remember that Donald Trump's
previous secretary press secretary
Stephanie Grisham held 0.0 press
conferences press briefings during her
entire time as press secretary Kayleigh
mäkinen he did one of I believe it was
Friday and she did one yesterday now in
her fur
one she famously pledged not to lie to
the press then she told four major lies
- related to the Russia investigation
one related to ventilators and one
related to Michael Flynn so in about
three minutes
she broke her pledge not to lie
yesterday
12 seconds into the press briefing she
lied by claiming that the u.s. is doing
the most testing merely by saying we've
done 7 million tests of course as you
all know what matters is per capita in a
country of 331 million people now the
last time that we covered her press
briefings I pointed out the press corps
needs to ask her about that time she
went on Fox News in February and said
Trump will never allow coronavirus to
come to the United States here's what
she said back in February
absolutely this president will always
put America first he will always protect
American citizens we will not see
diseases like the corona virus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing when contrasting
it with the awful presidency of
President Obama Caylee mcenamey thank
you so much good to see you thank you
now to his credit Jeff Mason from
Reuters yesterday asked her about
exactly those comments here is how she
handled it she turned to a particular
page in her notebook
she knew the question might show up she
was prepared here's how she addressed it
he worked for the campaign and he made a
comment I believe on Fox in which he
said President Trump will not allow the
coronavirus to come to this car
given what has happened since then
obviously would you like to take that
back well first let me note I was asked
a question on Fox Business about
presents travel restrictions I noted
what was the intent behind those travel
restrictions which is we will not see
the coronavirus come here we will not
see terrorism come here referring to an
earlier set of travel restrictions I
guess I would turn the question back on
the media and ask similar questions does
Vox want to take back that they proclaim
that the coronavirus would not be a
deadly pandemic does the Washington Post
want to take back that they told
Americans to get a grip the flu is
bigger than the coronavirus which is the
Washington Post likewise want to take
back that our brains are causing us to
exaggerate the threats of the
coronavirus does the New York Times want
to take back that fear of the virus may
be expressed
spreading faster than the virus itself
does NPR want to take back that the flu
was a much bigger threat than the corona
virus and finally once again the
Washington Post would they like to take
back but the government should not
respond aggressively to the corona virus
I'll leave you with those questions and
maybe you'll have some answers what's so
funny about this is that she clearly
feels like that was a huge mic drop
moment where she walks off after turning
it back around on the press it's
actually cringe-worthy and the entire
thing was cringe-worthy she may not last
long because it's it's getting more and
more embarrassing now the trumpet seemed
to be liking it that's what might keep
her in the job she starts the briefing
35 minutes late it lasts only 25 minutes
total
after taking only a few questions she
abruptly walks off after being asked
about a completely laughable ridiculous
thing that she said but the trumpets
love it Donald Don junior tweeted
yesterday saying her answer was fire and
a whole bunch of trumpets are just
thrilled with Kayleigh Mackin Annie so
let's analyze her argument she said
Trump won't let coronavirus come to the
United States and she responds by saying
listen a lot of media outlets said this
is not going to be a big deal in the
United States that's a terrible argument
number one it's not really an argument
it's actually the to quote way follows
see which is the appeal to hypocricy is
another way to say it which is when you
try to discredit your opponent's
argument about something you did by
pointing out that someone else did the
same thing and that it's it's fallacious
strictly speaking how can the media
criticize her when they said similar
things supposedly as the way the
argument goes now first of all when the
media was saying this may not be a big
deal in the United States the media was
reporting what different medical experts
were saying many of whom were people
that were involved with the Trump
administration and so one thing to
understand is a lot of the articles
she's quoting are articles that are
essentially citing the medical experts
that the Trump administration picked to
say things about coronavirus that's
number one it's not like the media
reports when you look at independent and
foreign experts we're not saying this
would be a big deal in fact you can look
at January and February and find a whole
bunch of media reports that are not
based on what Trump affiliated medical
experts were saying if you look at
foreign countries if you look at
independent agencies in the u.s. they
were saying we could take actions that
would prevent this but if we don't it's
going to be a disaster so she's she's
actually wrong about that and a lot of
the reports that she cites were simply
saying here's what someone associated
with the administration says is going to
happen
she didn't say here's what an expert
says she simply said Trump won't allow
the virus to come here so she made a
very different type of claim when she
went on Fox News and said Obama's
presidency was awful Trump's not going
to allow it to come here that was not
these are the medical experts alleging
that now secondly none of those media
people who were simply reporting what
was being said were hired to be Trump's
press secretary right the question about
her competence is a very valid and good
question because she was hired to be
Trump's press secretary some Vox writer
who quoted a health expert who may have
been wrong or may have been taken out or
whatever they are not now speaking for
the president but clearly what she has
done is show her hand she is very much
willing to attack
Media she is prepared to attack the
media whenever she gets a question she
doesn't like very much like Donald Trump
does that's what we've learned make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david patten show we'll
be back very soon the david pakman show
at david pakman.com the David Pakman
show depends on your support and the
easiest way is through membership which
includes the world-famous bonus show as
well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show just for members
sign up today at join pakman.com coupon
code saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome
back to the David Pakman show
so yesterday Donald Trump viciously
snapped at a nurse who is just the nurse
she's not a politician she was just
telling the truth that she experienced
it which was that she had had only
sporadic access to PPE like masks and
gowns and face shields and Trump didn't
like it Trump did his thing where he
crosses his arms like a petulant child
and he snapped at her and said well
maybe your access was sporadic but
that's not what I'm hearing take a look
at the video so PPE has been a sporadic
but it's been manageable and we do what
we have to do we're nurses and we learn
to adapt and do whatever the best thing
that we can do for our patients to get
the job done and get the care provided
and that's what we're going to continue
to do as hope in 19 continues sporadic
for you but that's Braddock for a lot of
other people oh no I agree mr. president
because I've heard the opposite I
learned that they are loaded up with
with gowns now and pick it honestly we
had nothing we had empty cupboards
she wasn't even saying anything that bad
right I mean access to PPE has been
sporadic but manageable she says it's
not like a huge attack on Trump it's not
really an attack on Trump at all but
Trump says well maybe it was sporadic
for you but not
other people oh yes yes yes mr.
president she says and of course Donald
Trump claims this is all because of the
empty cupboards that Barack Obama left
him and this has to be called out now
when Trump says the PPE problems were
because the cupboards were bare Trump's
had three and a half years now how is it
still even if you accept it was Obama's
fault which is ridiculous but even if
you accept it was Obama's fault that
there wasn't PPE when Trump took over
it's been three and a half years yours
Longet Trump couldn't get masks in three
and a half years it's really really weak
weak stuff now I want to be really clear
Trump doing this to a nurse is
completely heartless she's not a
politician this is a nurse who treats
patients doctors have the Hippocratic
oath nurses have the nightingale pledge
named for florence nightingale it's
similar to the Hippocratic oath in a lot
of ways it says in short don't do
anything that but might be bad for
patients take care of sick people that's
what nurses do she has had sporadic
access to PPE and Trump can't accept it
without a rebuttal and snapping at her
now I don't blame the nurse for what I'm
about to say she's not a politician
she's a nurse it would be great if
someone in one of these situations
instead of saying yes yes yes mr.
president of course it would be better
if they said you've been misinformed mr.
president if that's what you heard you
weren't told the truth I know the truth
because I'm on the front lines
I'm not criticizing this nurse it's not
her job to go there and to criticize
Donald Trump but it would be great for
someone to publicly do it a health
worker in the room with Trump it would
go instantly viral if they were to do it
last thing Trump again during this
photo-op brings up the entire we've done
more tests than anyone lie let's take a
look at that I watch this phony Chuck
Schumer everyone in New York knows he's
a total phony he brought nothing back to
New York except salt you know what salt
is bad tax policy
he brought salt back he didn't even
fight it I watched him the other night
on a show and all he could talk about
was testing too
testing and yet I showed a chart
yesterday where our testing is far
superior to anybody else's testing and
then the other thing is very interesting
because we did so much more testing we
have more cases if I did a little
testing we'd have practically no cases
so the headline was we have more cases
than anyone else well China has more
cases than us and other big countries
you know you're talking about the
country but they don't want to choose
they don't want to use that so I know
I'm sounding like a broken record I will
continue to fact chess fact check this
for as long as Donald Trump and Kaylie
mcenany and everybody else keep lying
about it we do not have enough testing
we are not the best in the world at
testing we are 41st in testing in the
world per capita 7 million tests don't
matter if you have 331 million people
Iceland is second in the world in per
capita testing Israel is 13th in the
world in per capita testing Portugal is
15 Spain is 20th Norway is 26th we are
41st in the world in per capita
coronavirus testing in terms of tests
per day remember health experts have
said we need to at least get to 500,000
tests a day to even think about opening
and over the last 10 days or so we can't
get past an average of 250 thousand
tests per day so after two months of
this we are in really three months we
are just now getting halfway to the
absolute minimum number we need to think
about opening and 500,000 tests today is
just a starting point we ideally would
pass 500,000 a day on route to a million
a day on route to 2 million tests a day
Trump is failing hugely it's tragic it's
embarrassing but he's snapping at nurses
who tell the truth back briefly to the
PPE thing there are health care workers
who are dying because they're getting
the virus there are health care workers
in places that still are rationing PPE
wearing masks longer than they should
for example and Trump who has been
president for three and a half years is
simultaneously say
there's more than enough PPE but also
saying any shortage is because Obama
left the cupboards bare
even though it's been three and a half
years it has to stop
I received a very interesting email from
a neuroscientist this week and this
neuroscience has said you know David you
should just look at the verbal symptoms
of schizophrenia rather than dementia or
drug abuse to explain Donald Trump's
behavior and I want to dig right into
this now let me put the disclaimer right
out there I am NOT a neuroscientist I am
NOT coming up with any of this stuff and
I am NOT diagnosing Trump with anything
what I'm doing is pointing out we've
been looking at Trump's brain glitches
his speech patterns his bizarre behavior
is walking away from his limo when it
was right in front of him he's not
seeing Rudy Giuliani when Rudy Giuliani
was right in front of him talking about
the oranges of an investigation hath
Safa hide all of that stuff right we
have heard from professionals who say
it's cognitive decline we've heard from
professionals who say it's dementia
we've heard it could be a side effect of
medication could be drug abuse okay a
lot of different ideas a neuroscientist
wrote to me and said David look at the
language disturbances that are outlined
in schizophrenia and just see what you
think so I did it
peer-reviewed journal article from this
year journal is called current opinions
on psychiatry the article is called
anomalies or anomalies both are valid
pronunciations anomalies in language as
a biomarker for schizophrenia and it
says that impaired verbal communication
is one of the key diagnostic features of
schizophrenia spectrum disorders and it
lists the following traits and I have to
tell you Trump does seem to experience
every single one of these difficulties
with lexical selection and retrieval
Trump has that issue disturbances in
priming and reduced syntactic priming
Trump it has that reduced proactive
inhibition difficulties with coherently
generating a narrative Trump can't
maintain a coherent narrative when he
speaks
using neologisms word approximation
disturbances in cohesion vague
references missing information and
confused references it's like it's
describing Trump speech sentences with
reduced syntactic complexity less
dependence and embedded clauses and use
fewer connective markers that is Donald
Trump's simplistic childish speech
described to a tee compared with normal
speech the speech of those experiencing
schizophrenia contains more hesitations
pauses and longer pauses that's Trump
intonation is flat and monotonous that
is Trump we've actually talked about you
know we say when when Trump talks about
the number of deaths and cases and the
the the tragedy and suffering of
coronavirus we notice he seems to
completely lack empathy it also
interpreted differently could be what
the biomarkers the verbal biomarkers of
schizophrenia described as a flat
monotonous intonation so I'm not
bringing this to you as a diagnosis I am
NOT coming up with this what I'm telling
you is a neuroscientist pointed out look
at this just take a look at it and see
if it fits and boy does it fit let me
know your thoughts oh we will take a
quick break and follow up on this very
very soon the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so we have leaked audio of the horrible
Texas Republican governor Greg Abbott
admitting something obvious which is
that reopening the economy of Texas is
going to spread the corona virus this is
no big surprise it's no great
realization but it's important because
it is not that Greg Abbott doesn't
believe reopening will spread the virus
it's that he's decided reopening makes
sense even though it will spread the
virus and The Daily Beast got a hold of
this audio which is from right after
Greg Abbott letting the Texas
stay-at-home order expired this was on a
call with it's amazing because behind
closed doors sometimes they actually
sound like rational people if you just
isolated that audio of saying here's
what the medical experts are saying it
will increase the spread period they
don't sound that different than the
responsible governor's that we've seen
manage these crises some of which are
Democrats and some of which are
Republicans it's refreshing in a sense
but of course he's still reopening the
state and the numbers aren't looking so
good and it only proves that what he's
doing is not out of ignorance it's
actually out of indifference and the
media went right after Abbott for
comment after this audio leaked his
spokesperson John Whitman said oh no no
no this is no big deal
all the governor is saying here is that
medical experts claim that there could
be more cases but we're doing more
testing so everything is completely fine
that is the epitome of what you call
crisis management and spin now another
response has been life has risk this is
not just Texas now but we've heard this
from a lot we've heard it from our
favorite right-wing ideological
commentators and from governors and all
over the place
life has risk if you want to really be
safe you've got to stay in your house
all the time forever and even in your
house you could end up dying of carbon
monoxide poisoning if you leave your gas
stove on or whatever I mean it's it's
really quite cynical and of course in a
literal sense any action including
merely leaving your house increases your
risk to some degree of catching a
communicable disease and again even in
your house there is not a zero level
risk of catching a communicable disease
or of getting hurt in some other way but
this is not some vague thing this is a
really specific decision right now about
reopening when we know we have a
communicable disease spreading for which
we have no vaccine and only are starting
to figure out some treatments that have
some effect but they don't care they've
decided that and this is important
they've decided that the facade of the
economy is what matters I'm not even
going to say the economy because what
they really care about is the facade of
the economy which we experience through
the stock market the sort of political
perspective on whether Trump has done a
good job justifying his reelection
the facade is what they care about and
many states have decided that that is
what they care about
Friday Greg Abbott is allowing tanning
salons hair salons barber shops to
reopen getting people off of
unemployment also seems to be a big
impetus for pushing this and that is
driving a lot of states to decide to
reopen more and more of the economy or
at least to allow more and more of the
economy to reopen and anytime you're
talking about Greg Abbott you also have
to wonder about the role of oil oil and
gas prices gasoline I'm talking about
have collapsed because there's no demand
airplanes aren't flying people aren't
driving much opening states will get
people at least driving that'll increase
demand for oil and gasoline and there's
always you know
and angles on this and all of them are
ugly now how are the numbers looking in
Texas not too good
Texas going from roughly four to five
hundred new cases a day in mid-april now
they are regularly in the range of 800
to 1200 new cases understand that the
federal narrative by that I mean Trump
the narrative has been were past the
peak we are well past the peak since
April 12th or so he's been talking about
being past the peak Texas's new cases
per day have doubled in the last 15 days
what the Trump administration is
pretending is going on is make-believe
it is only pretending the opposite is
happening and happening in many states
the death numbers of course lagging
cases to some degree but those also
starting to climb in Texas since the
last days of April many states clearly
not on the downswing and Texas appears
to be one of those let's go from Texas
to Arizona one way to avoid cases is not
to do any tests one way to avoid
opinions that you shouldn't reopen your
state yet is to fire the people telling
you not to reopen the state and that is
what Arizona Republican Governor Doug
Ducey did on Monday Ducey said he is
accelerating the reopening of Arizona
that seemed questionable based on the
case numbers which if you look have a
very definitive upward curve spiking to
nearly a new high yesterday matched only
by the numbers on April 30th so the
cases are spiking deaths usually follow
closely behind and Ducey says let's open
up
well income the public health officials
who say hey you know look at the numbers
we can't really reopen right now Ducey
doesn't like it so he fires them
Steve Bailey the bureau chief for Public
Health Statistics at the Arizona
Department of Health Services says quote
we've been asked by Department
leadership to pause all current work on
projections and modeling yeah pause it
until the pandemic is gone and then
start modeling again how great the
numbers are these are the people we
should be listening to now the timing is
suspect the timing to me has Trump's
fingerprints all over it and it seems to
have Trump's pressure all over it
because remember that trump was in
Arizona on Tuesday and the day before
Trump shows up Ducey says we're gonna
reverse course from what I said last
week a week ago the governor in Arizona
seemed to be taking this seriously
extended to stay homeowner or stay at
home order until May 15 said stay at
home is working said the data clearly
point to not opening up yet
but then this week we learned Trump's
going to Arizona on Tuesday does a bunch
of grandstanding about reopening and the
great governor Ducey who is there and
getting the economy going again and just
hours before Trump went to Arizona the
day before Ducey decides hey you know
what we are going to open more stuff we
don't need the public health officials
modeling the impact of reopening anymore
and it has Trump's fingerprints all over
it speculative but it's what we know
Trump does Arizona not the only state
that is starting to do strange things we
already talked about Texas five minutes
ago we have reports that Florida or
Florida as some say is hiding
coronavirus deaths by not reporting the
cause of death people are dying the
reporting that a death took place there
not including the cause of death in the
reports to the media and publicly we
have reports that Ohio is changing how
it reports numbers from a five-day to a
21-day timeframe to make it seem as
though the numbers are going down what I
believe is going on here and I believe
Donald Trump's past behavior and
statements justify at least exploring
this is that the efforts are becoming
more about let's not talk about the
deaths let's not talk about anything
that's going on medically let's just
insist we're past the peak and let's
talk about reopening let's talk about
CEOs and States and all of this other
states opening businesses and all of
that and as usual the very thing the
Trump administration is accusing others
of doing is what it seems like they
themselves are doing some use the term
projection to describe this we're
hearing more and more that the
administration is questioning whether
the death numbers are accurate or
whether they are higher than the real
numbers meanwhile what we're learning
about are the strategies being employed
by the Trump administration and by
States to make it a case that the death
numbers are actually lower than what
they really are while insisting that the
testing is greater than what it actually
is Trump can keep repeating 2.2 million
deaths all he wants but he for week said
60,000 60,000 60,000 we're now at 75,000
yesterday 2,500 people died the day
before roughly 2500 people died at this
rate we will be at a hundred thousand
cases in ten days and it's going to
continue going and it's a fiasco while
Spain Italy France many other countries
have it under control
don't take my word for it look at the
data coming out of Italy Spain and
France so what do you do if you're the
Trump administration when you've lost
control of the situation you just lie
you say the death toll is lower than
what we were told and I'm doing a great
job
and testing is great and we're opening
up the country it's a disaster and
people will continue to die we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two David P and I appreciate this
this is a voicemail about Joe Biden
dropping out okay let's listen to it
first and then I'll give you my thoughts
hi this is Kathy wood from Illinois and
I'm wondering what are our chances of
getting Biden to drop out so we can get
a progressive in there I'd like to see
Biden I mean excuse me not Biden I'd
like to see Bernie Sanders my second
choice would be Elizabeth one um they
could jump right back in if your Biden
to drop out my number is six whoa okay
all I don't want to put her number out
there so listen I I'm getting more and
more enquiries about the the Biden drop
out movement we've got to be realistic
okay everybody else has ended their
campaign and Biden's winning every poll
now
I already saw some some people who don't
seem to understand much of what's going
on on our subreddit saying you can't
trust the polls or the polls were wrong
in 2016 polls were basically right
nationally they said Hillary would win
by three she basically won by three but
this is not my opinion of whether the
polls are accurate what I'm telling you
is look in history when people are
winning every poll and everybody else
has dropped out they don't end their
campaigns now there are people talking
about Biden's cognitive decline there
are people talking about the sexual
assault allegation against Biden by Tara
Reid from 1993 there are people just
saying you know Biden didn't actually
get all the delegates he needs yet well
but he has more than anybody else I
think if you're just waiting around
thinking Biden will quote come to his
senses and cancel his campaign while he
is winning every poll you've not paid
attention to how history works unless
Biden dies or is in a coma or something
radically new or different happens that
really torpedoes his campaign people
don't end their campaigns when they're
winning every poll he may lose to Donald
Trump in November
maybe the polls are wrong I'm not
analyzing the polls I'm merely saying
the focus on this to me does not seem
like a particularly good use of time
versus lobbying Joe Biden to adopt more
progressive policies for example getting
Bernie to ask Joe I will you know be out
there with you every single day if you
can do these two things to your policy
and a noun right that seems like a much
better use of our time we have a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the tax cuts that Donald Trump
wants we will talk about a ruling that
says New York will do their Democratic
primary they were going to cancel it and
a judge said no no no you've got to do
it we will also talk about restaurant
workers being told don't wear a face
mask don't wear a face mask if you or
don't work that is the choice that in
Texas in Dallas some reopened restaurant
workers are being told all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up get instant access at join
Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video